welcome to the show everybody thanks for
watching I hope you've had a great
morning so far so I want to get into
something I wrote about yesterday I
wrote a piece yesterday called the what
was it called oh the four things that
are destroying boys in our culture and I
want to get my I want to talk about that
I want to bring that conversation over
to this forum as well because I think
it's so important especially in a
society where we hear so much about we
hear about two things quite a bit we
hear number one that boys are privileged
that men are privileged there's this
this mystical male privilege that we're
always told about and that's you know we
rarely see it manifest into anything
into into anything tangible but we're
told that it's there that men are men
are so privileged to be in this culture
and then number two worked we're told
about the persecution and the oppression
of women and in the midst of all this
while we're having this discussion about
male privilege and while we've got
feminists complaining about other so
they're so persecuted they're persecuted
because you know female actresses in
Hollywood don't make as much a female
actress in a movie made only 5 million
dollars while a male actor on the same
movie made 15 million oh my gosh while
we're talking about that kind of
persecution or or oh oh my goodness you
you don't want to pay for my birth
control are you kidding me I'm oppressed
pay for my birth control so while we're
having that conversation boys
concentrating specifically here on boys
on young men they are dying I mean
literally dying in many cases but also
inside guy men are dying inside there's
this emptiness this this confusion this
kind of hollow Ness that we are
fostering in boys and so I want to
discuss that and talk about the things
that that lead
that you know the great the great two
challenges that boys face in our culture
or another way of putting it the
disadvantages there are some unique
disadvantages that men particularly
young boys suffer in our culture that
women either do not suffer at all or
they don't suffer at all to the same
degree so the first thing and I talked
about this in the video I did yesterday
as well but I want to focus on because I
think this is one aspect of the plight
of men that isn't focused on nearly
enough but our culture just relentlessly
preys upon a boys weaknesses we now I
just imagine the world that a 13 year
old boy inhabits okay just put yours if
you can just put yourself into the into
the world into the mindset put yourself
into the shoes of a of a 13 year old boy
of the average 13 year old boy in
America so if you're this boy that means
that you know you've long since been
exposed to hardcore pornography you
probably watch it regularly the average
age of first exposure to pornography is
I think 10 or 11 by according to most
studies and I think that that's I think
that's a pretty conservative estimate I
think for many kids it's much much
younger than that but let's say 10 or 11
so he's long since been exposed to
hardcore pornography i watch as it
regularly probably doesn't really
understand what it is or why he's even
finds it appealing but he watches it and
then puberty hits at right around 30 and
his hormones are going crazy they're
going haywire inside his head his brain
is hardwiring itself to focus
obsessively on sex now that isn't his
fault he didn't he didn't choose this
this is just how he is this is what this
is the biological imperative
there's bit there's there was a study
done a little while ago that said that
men I forget how it was phrased exactly
but basically men focus
more on sex than they do on food so if a
man had to choose between food or sex he
would take sex I think some of that
stuff is kind of sensational I I think
you know if a guy's starving to death in
the desert he has to choose between the
two things he's probably gonna take the
food I would think but even if that's a
little sensational we know the reality
is that especially for boys when they're
going through puberty there is this
intense preoccupation with sex that just
kind of hits them all all of a sudden
like a ton of bricks and they don't even
know where it's coming from they don't
understand it and he feels just this
biological impulse to go out and to find
a sexual partner even though he he
doesn't understand this urge his
conception of human sexuality has been
perverted and degraded and confused by
the porn habit he developed in sixth
grade but still he is now at the age of
13 a boy becomes fertile a fertile a boy
can conceive a child at the age of 13
even even though girls his age for the
most part are not fertile so this is
this is again this is biology this is
his body doing this saying oh well now
you can have babies now you're gonna be
focused on sex and the boy even though
of course he's too young for all this
he's too young for sex but he can't
escape but it can't escape sex it's all
over his computer it's all over his
phone it's all over social media it's
all over the TV it's all over the music
he listens to it's all over the
advertisements he's you know it's it's
billboards and just everything
everywhere he turns you know even the
magazine rack and the supermarket I mean
everywhere he turns and he's his
hormones are already going crazy he's
already preoccupied in everywhere he
turns there's this temptation there's
this there's this preying upon what's
already preoccupying his head and then
he goes to school and he sees that his
female classmates are dressed like
strippers and in fact most of the places
that he go that he goes in life that's
how the women are dressed
because they say well this is my body
it's my purge in oh you just don't look
it's not my problem it's not my problem
if I'm you know leading these boys into
sin it doesn't start not my problem at
all it's your problem I don't care about
them because that's the attitude that
we've fostered in girls it seems that
everyone is doing everything they can to
make a degenerate and a creep out of
them even as they demand that he not
become a degenerate or a creep
they're doing everything they can
literally everything they can to make
him into one while saying well hey never
become this thing that we are trying our
hardest to turn you into and so we
demand self-discipline we demand
self-control from this boy while
providing him absolutely no tools
whatsoever to develop them and rather
than tools we just give him temptation
upon temptation upon temptation non-stop
temptation everywhere he goes all day
every day right at the moment when his
brain is least able to cope with it or
overcome it and even if so that's all
bad enough even if the boy possesses
this kind of superhuman moral fortitude
the kind of moral fortitude that he's
gonna need to pursue chastity and purity
in the midst of this in the midst of
this degenerate sex-crazed culture even
if he has that well what's he gonna meet
when he goes out and he and he tries to
pursue chastity and purity what's he
gonna mean from our society mockery
discouragement the very people who
demand that he respect women and control
himself
those same people will then heap scorn
on him if he tries to do exactly what
they demand he do we we blame boys for
not being virtuous enough and then if
they try to be virtuous we laugh at them
that's the situation of boys in
again in that case the boy is going to
need to call upon this kind of
superhuman courage one more time so he
can just like he rejected the
temptations now he has to now he has to
reject all the jeers and everything so
he can walk this path to virtue and he's
gonna have to walk it on his own from
with no help from anyone including his
parents much of the time because that
brings us to the second disadvantage in
our culture there is a lack of male
leadership and male role models and it
is truly catastrophic we know some of
the statistics we know that 20% of the
kids in this country grow up without
dads in the home that's 17 million kids
in the black community the percentage is
70 or 80 percent okay 70 to 80 percent
of the kids in the black community grow
up in fatherless homes which is again a
catastrophic apocalyptic number that a
community cannot survive like that when
you've when you've only got when you've
only got 20 to 30 percent of your kids
who have dads at home now on the other
hand almost every kid has a mother in
the home with rare exception so a girl
will have a female role model in her
mother and not only that but when she
goes to school most of the teachers I
think 75 76 percent of teachers in the
public school system are women so she
goes to school and she's got female role
models at school and she's even more
likely to have a grandmother in her life
than a grandfather because men died five
or six years before before before women
do so she's got no shortage of female
role models she's got female role models
just basically falling out of the sky I
mean they're everywhere everywhere she
turns there's a female role model which
is great and we should celebrate that we
should be happy for that that's a
fantastic thing it's also a profound
advantage that girls have over boys even
though boys have privilege they're so
privileged but they're not even
privileged enough to have
dad around to say hey this is what a man
is supposed to do
and even the boys who have dads in the
home that doesn't mean that they have
male role models you'll find very often
that despite the father's physical
presence the mother is still the
spiritual leader in the home among
Christians I don't know what the exact
number is but statistically it's the
mother who takes the child the children
to church while the dad stays home and
his pajamas too lazy to even get up and
go to church she's the one who takes
over the religious duties of the family
in most families now the the mother is
the spiritual leader so the father what
is the father he's a warm body you know
you know taking up space he's a he's a
paycheck maybe hopefully he goes out and
brings home a paycheck at least but many
of these dads they're not leading their
family and they are not providing an
example to their sons they're just
leaving their sons hanging them out to
dry and saying hey you figure it out so
if a boy wants to be a man if he wants
to know how to be a man and that by the
way is something that we need to teach
kids a boy needs to be taught how to be
a man a girl needs to be taught how to
be a girl how to be a woman but of many
boys they don't have anyone around to
teach them that so either they can turn
to their mother and they can hope that
their mother can somehow teach them how
to be a man and she can do her best and
she can even do a heroic job in trying
to teach that lesson but she's never
going to be able to do it the way that a
man can because when it comes to how to
be a man a woman can tell you based on
her observations what she thinks a man
does but she cannot show you she's a
woman
all she can show you is what a woman
does it takes a man to show another man
what a man does so if he doesn't have if
he doesn't want to turn to his mother
then what's he gonna do
what what do many boys in this culture
do what's the next place you can't you
can't look in the home you don't look to
the schools you know you're not going to
church you can't look to the church so
where do you look then for your male
role model you turn on the TV and many
of these boys now they're turning to
musicians they're turning to actors
celebrities superheroes for their idea
of masculinity and they developed this
cartoonish kind of hollow idea of
manhood and they become cartoonish
Hollow Men that's what I noticed when I
you know when I look around I see a lot
of cartoon men walking around do you
know what I mean
a lot of these men they're cartoons
they've got this idea of masculinity
that's cartoonish and they're walking
around it's like they're wearing a
costume because they don't even know who
they are so that's another disadvantage
third the education system is designed
for girls there's a reason why girls
outperform men outperform boys in the
school system and it's not because
they're smarter statistically you know
girls are not any smarter than boys yet
they do so much better in school even
though the boys with all their privilege
somehow they can't even get somehow they
can't even get good grades in school why
is that because the classroom is set up
is set up to foster or to cater to the
girls it is set up to reward the kind of
calm organized demeanor that's natural
to girls boys are not like that for the
most part with exception boys are not
like that boys are rambunctious they
have physical energy you know they're
they have trouble sitting still I got a
four-year-old boy at home this is him
totally I mean he's got he's bouncing
off the walls he's got all this energy
he's got trouble sitting still he
doesn't like sitting still
you know he's not able to focus
intentive attentively on a dull task for
a prolonged period of time my daughter
can sit there and you know she can draw
a picture she could she could sit still
for for an hour or more and just do
something I mean she could sit there and
brush her dolls hair she could set up a
tea party she could do something like
that
meanwhile my son is bouncing off the
walls he's pretending to be the Hulk
he's you know that's what he's doing
he's saying daddy let's play can we go
let's play tag let's play hide-and-seek
and we go outside I mean he wants to do
things that's what that's what boys want
to do but the classroom is not designed
for kids like that it doesn't know what
to do with them it can't do anything
with them so it penn Eliza's them it
penalized his boys for being boys as a
result boys get lower grades boys are
more likely to drop out of school for
boys are more likely to be expelled to
be suspended remember with all their
privilege we've all got this privilege
but they're failing out of school
they're dropping out they're getting a
spell they're getting suspended and
worst of all I think cuz that boys are
twice as likely to be diagnosed with
ADHD listen listen to this figure okay
by high school
20% of boys will have been diagnosed
with ADHD and a large number of them
will be on drugs somehow you know we
never stopped to ask ourselves why is it
that boys are somehow more susceptible
to this mysterious mental condition
that's crazy isn't it if this is really
just a mental condition and anyone could
get it then why does it always affect
boys why are boys the white what can
anyone explain that we never stopped to
consider that maybe what we're doing
it's that we're not diagnosing
individual boys with ADHD what we're
doing instead is we are diagnosing
boyhood itself
we are saying boyhood itself is a
disease and there's no place for it at
school now if the school system were not
predicated on sitting still and
memorizing and regurgitating information
and filling out dittos and worksheets
okay if the school system were not
predicated on that there would be no
ADHD it would be like magic all the ATH
ADHD class cases in the world
will just evaporate it would be gone
because it's all conditional ADHD exists
in the classroom it doesn't exist in the
woods when there we know when your son
goes out and plays in the woods and he's
planned he's playing with sticks and
he's climbing trees
there's note and there's no ADHD there
is there there's no ADHD in a tree in a
tree fort it's only in a classroom
because we've decided that will we need
boys to sit still for seven hours a day
five days a week for 12 years nine
months out of the year repeating
information that's what we need them to
do and if they can't do it we will stuff
pills into their face and make them and
if they still can't do it
kick them out of school but that's
privileged that's their privilege I mean
seriously before you tell me about male
privilege have we turned womanhood into
a disease
well actually we kind of had that's
that's we actually have done that with
the birth control pill but that's that's
a that's a different conversation
number four masculinity is is denigrated
in this culture now you'd think after we
just got through the first three steps
and you'd think well that's enough I
mean we can lay off now right we've done
enough to these boys we've thrown sex in
their face every second of the day
we have deprived them of role models
we have put them into an education
system that treats their personality as
a disease so we've done all that I mean
aren't we satisfied now can we just
leave them alone at that point can we
just let them be but no because if they
managed to survive that gauntlet then
the next step is we bury them under just
mounds and mounds of self-loathing we
attack masculinity
now femininity is also attacked in our
culture but not nearly as explicitly not
directly okay nobody is is is is going
around and saying that femininity is
toxic or fragile nobody talks about
female privilege nobody does that
nobody's gonna say that all women are
dangerous nobody's saying that these are
the special denigration x' and
accusations that are reserved for men
and for boys so think about what happens
think about a boy you know just follow
along these four steps and think about a
boy that falls into every category I've
listed and that's that's millions of
boys do there are millions of boys who
you start with they're watching porn at
10:00 or 11:00 they hit puberty they're
dealing with all that they don't have a
dad at home they go to school they get
diagnosed with ADHD they're told there's
something wrong there their entire time
they spend 12 13 years in in grade
school and the entire time they're there
they're told there's something wrong
with you there's something wrong with
you sit down shut up repeat the
information on the did oh shut up sit
down there's something wrong with you
you're diseased you have a condition
take this pill why didn't you take your
pill today and that's what the boy is
dealing with for 12 or 13 years and then
he comes out and let's say he manages to
go to college and that's when the
feminism hits him and that's when the
feminists go after Abby he's just he's
barely he could barely walk he's
emerging from this gauntlet like just
just just bruised and
a turd and and on drugs and everything
and he gets to college and then that's
what you're a man you've got privileged
men are dangerous and then at that point
it's just his defenses are down he's
susceptible to it there's nothing you
can do so after we have broken men down
broken boys down I should say the final
step now that we have them like putty in
our hands now the final step is to
remove their masculinity from them
a masculinity that they've never really
come into in the first place
that they never understood that they
never grew into because they they never
had because of the last three things I
mentioned and so it's not very hard for
our culture then to come in and the
feminists and the college colleges they
can come in and they could just take
this masculinity that's already bruised
and battered and they just remove it
from the man and feminized him why do
you think it is there's another medical
mystery here so we've got the medical
mystery of why is it mostly boys that
have ADHD
another medical mystery is why is it
mostly men that are transgender have you
noticed that most of these stories that
you hear about transgender
eight-year-old eight-year-olds whose
parents are so accepting of it which is
by the way their parents are abusive and
should be in prison but their parents
are so accepting in almost every case
it's a boy turning into a girl and then
as you get older the transgender
community is the transgender community
is comprised primarily of men why is
that could it have something to do with
the fact that there is a crisis of
identity in American manhood there is a
crisis of identity because we've got
these boys who grow up and they never
learn what it means to be a man
they never learned to embrace their
masculinity they never learned to see it
as a good and constructive and a
beautiful thing they never learned to
that that that you know there's a place
for men in society that they never
learned that society needs men to be men
and to do certain things and to you know
men are the ones who're fighting the
wars and building the bridges and
building the buildings of protecting and
providing its men doing that mostly I
mean men literally literally built this
civilization but they don't learn that
because that would be upsetting you know
to the feminists and that might hurt a
girl's feeling so we can't talk about
that and so that means so what do we do
we all of the things that men uniquely
contribute we say you can't talk about
that no you don't you're not unique at
all you don't contribute anything
special at all shut up you're sexist
patriarchy how dare you suggest that
there's anything special about being a
man there's nothing special about you
you're not special being a man is
nothing a woman can do would do anything
that a man can do that's what we say to
men but to women we say oh my gosh being
a woman is beautiful it's a special you
could do anything I mean the world needs
women I mean we need more women CEOs and
more women in business we need more
women in the mill that we need women we
need more women we need women
Ghostbusters and women's superheroes we
need women all over the place because
you know we can't it just meant women
are so special and then a boy tries to
pipe up and say well what about me I'll
shut up you and then somehow
mysteriously we end up with a bunch of
men who are feminized and in some cases
literally feminized they literally try
to become women I think all these things
are related and I think we need to face
this because this is what our sons will
face and we should look away from it
and if we care about our sons and we
love our sons then we need to prepare
them to deal with all these things
because this is the world that they're
entering into alright everybody thank
you for watching and I'll talk to you
tomorrow